depuis quelques jours l'union nationale
des étudiants de france est dans le
viseur de certains médias et
responsables politiques
en cause la rumeur persistante que
certaines des réunions organisées par
l'unef serait interdite aux blancs sur
repos mélanie luce la présidente de
l'unef a répondu à ces accusations
des faits qu'elle reconnaît mais elle
souhaite tout de même remettre les
choses dans leur contexte
mélanie luce précise que oui les
personnes blanches ne sont pas invités à
certaines réunions sur le thème du
racisme car elles n'en sont pas victimes
mais précise toutefois que lors de ces
rassemblements aucune décision n'est
plus au nom de l'unef
il ne s'agit là que de groupes de parole
malgré ces explications nombreux sont
ceux qui s'indignent de tel interdit et
demande aujourd'hui une dissolution de
l'association
alors une association étudiante et adil
et blanc lors de certaines réunions
trouvez vous ça choquant
bon alors une association étudiante
interdit les blancs lors de certaines
réunions trouvez vous ça choquant eric
naulleau merci d'être là pour tourner en
btp ce soir à 21h05 concret la
magnifique
eric qu'il fait des cartons d'audience
juste pour l'instant j'ai un petit
soucis et je vous le dis on dirait qu'il
est maintenant main il se passe un truc
mélanie lui ce qu'est ce qui se passe
eric que ce qu'elle est il à mélanie
elle est dans le couloir mais résidente
du syndicat ne veux pas rentrer pour des
motifs techniques que j'ai pas bien
saisi d'aller on me l'a dit sinon je lui
ai dit merci mélanie d'être là
bonjour ça va mais la vie qu'est ce qui
se passe ça va je sais pas où je vais
donc qu'est ce qui se passe mais naniwa
tue bradés qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous avez oublié votre portable
non non non je n'ai pas oublié mon
portable il est là ça va tout va bien et
vous ne vouliez pas rentrer non je ne
vais simplement m'expliquer sérieusement
pas comme ce qui s'est passé sur europe
1 donc je leur ai suggéré sur fond
notamment au népal auraient beaucoup la
radio
on aime beaucoup il ya beaucoup voilà
mais ici on va s'exprimer
on embrasse seulement sonia mabrouk mais
on va vous laisser vous exprimer vous
inquiétez pas ici alors je vous dire ici
on est très gentil non mais sérieux aux
entraînements on n'a pas les rangs des
très gentil donc mélanie il faut que
vous expliquer parce que moi voilà show
toujours les explications des gens
surtout quand il ya des polémiques
j'aime pas quand les gens s'acharnent
j'ai vu que sur les réseaux sociaux ça a
été un déferlement 1 contre melanie
contre votre association
on va revoir ce que vous avez dit
d'accord mélanie blouin ont fait ça
j'avais ramené les dossiers de m
division quoi allait revoir ses regards
des réunions je vous les planches on
exclut madame luce la question est
simple la réponse c'est que aujourd'hui
on trouvait une femme ont subi des
discriminations donc on organise des
réunions pour pouvoir pour permettre aux
femmes d'exprimer les discriminations
qu'elles peuvent subir et on organise
des réunions pour permettre aux
personnes qui sont effectivement touché
par le racisme de pouvoir exprimer ce
qu'elle subit
ça veut pas dire que c'est des réunions
dans laquelle on prendrait des décisions
il ya aucune décision qui est prise en
mx béland l'unef donc la norme inès on
considère que la lourdeur avec d'un côté
avec à la fois les personnes lorsque les
personnes changent de relations sur les
unions ou les olé
non blancs ne sont pas admis il est
blanc ne sont pas ennemis c'est ça mais
je le pense oui ça alors ça a été
aujourd'hui le sujet le plus commenté
on va avoir l'avis d'éric bien sûr dans
un instant mais ce qu'on n'aurait pas
les explications déjà 2000 à dire mais
déjà je vais commencer par vous faire
écouter quelque chose c'est quoi le
nouveau bon bah ouais c'est ça mais on
s'est tenus en exclusivité du poids je
ne vais pas récolté pensez quoi
je fais ce menton bon écoute espèce de
grosse [ __ ] je suis un homme blanc fiers
chez moi je suis dans mon pays qui n'est
pas le tien espèce de voilà messieurs
nous bat insultes et crois moi et je
pêche depuis de raciste couleur de peau
je m'auto rechute j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
moi j'aime juste mon pays je suis sur
les dindes au chili nationalistes blancs
ou le juste
on voit que je te préviens au nom de
tous les nations on en a tous les blancs
on cachera pas toi et ton et des tons et
on innove c'est tout je n'ai pas
trimestre ce qui alors c'est moi c'est
un message que j'ai reçu sur les réseaux
sociaux sur instagram oui j'ai pas tout
mais puisque vous avez le ton mais c'est
ça que voulez vous faire écouter j'avais
peur de pas avoir cette batterie c'est
tout concrètement si je commence par ça
c'est parce que sinon ça pourra pas
s'entendre
c'est pas la première fois que le
neversois ce genre de menaces je pense
que ça c'est assez grave y'a pas une
personne pour dénoncer ça dans ce pays
c'est à dire que j'ai dit plusieurs fois
qu'on avait menacé de me décapité il
m'avait menacée de mort là maintenant je
reçois sur leur demi ça j'ai dit menacé
de l'abaisser à près de souci je reviens
sur l'eonia là dessus ça c'est
inadmissible
les messages de ce genre il a décidé de
recevoir des messages du genre voilà et
met juste cette histoire d'ô réunion
anti blanc comprenez que c'est ça peut
choquer des gens mais c'est encore une
fois il faut de revenir sur qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est pas des réunions on
dirait que notamment quand vous
expliquer on faisait des rassemblements
qui seraient autorisés que enfin
interdit aux blancs c'est faux et
d'ailleurs le mot qu'on utilise c'est
pas des réunions interdit aux blancs ça
c'était les mots de sonia mabrouk l'unef
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle organise en
fait plus ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
groupes de parole des groupes de parole
pour les femmes pour les personnes qui
sont victimes de racisme et pour les
personnes lgbt dans l'organisation qui
veulent témoigner de ce qu'elles ont pu
subir
donc en fait c'est simplement un temps
où il ya des personnes qui se réunissent
et qui vont discuter de ce qu'elles ont
pu vivre c'est tout il n'y a pas de
décisions il n'y a pas même de
discussion sur comment on va s'organiser
pour lutter contre le racisme lutter
contre le sexisme et c est à la base
d'où ça vient ça vient du fait qu'en
2010 il ya des femmes dans l'unef qui
ont demandé à avoir ses cadres là pour
pouvoir s'exprimer sur ce qu'elle
subissait je pense que beaucoup de gens
ont entendu parler du fait que ma
pendant la vague nitoo l'unef a pas été
épargnée il ya des agressions que sont
le lieu est justement ces réunions ont
permis de remonter ce genre de choses
donc là on a foncé simplement la même
chose sur la question dit qu'on n'aurait
pas mal de mélanie luce vous convient
non pas du tout d'abord je voudrais
d'abord que dire que je suis désolé du
message que vous avez reçu ce genre soit
à peu près 10 par jour vous savez comme
ça et je pense qu'au tour de ce plateau
tout le monde pourra témoigner la même
serre lorsque vous êtes bienvenu sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux
non je vais je vais vous parler
courtoisement mais je vais vous parler
directement la gauche républicaine dont
je me réclame doit subir depuis des
années une autre gauche la gauche que
vous incarnez dont vous êtes la tête de
gondole une gauche délirante une gauche
irresponsable
une gauche islamo-gauchiste racialiste
indigéniste bien et je vais vous le dire
très franchement j'en ai marre nouveau
délire si vous ne comprenez pas à l'unef
que participé au lynchage médiatique de
deux professeurs à grenoble ça peut
avoir des conséquences tragiques les
conséquences criminelles
si vous ne comprenez pas qu interdire
des réunions à des hommes ou interdire d
on a des blancs contrevient à tous les
principes de la république et de la
france en général il n'y a plus qu'une
solution c'est celle que je réclame ici
ce soir la dissolution de votre syndic
15e n'est pas récente et moi je termine
et c'est ce qu'a demandé avec succès
presque fusionnel la démocratie la dgi
presque pas d'accord mais pas nos amis
j'ai presque fini
votre syndicat n'a rien à faire des
intérêts étudiants et tout à faire avec
des intérêts idéologiques vous êtes un
syndicat idéologique votre idéologie et
mortifère votre idéologie et dangereuse
vous ne cessez de jour après jour et cet
épisode n'est que le dernier en date
d'une longue suite de dérives et de
dérapages dit vraiment je suis pour la
destruction de notre syndicat et il
repart sur des bases plus saines toile a
donc déjà premier élément de réponse
je comprends pas pourquoi vous me dites
que on s'intéresse pas aux étudiants
concrètement où c'est pas moi qui ai
demandé de parler à parler de ça dans
cette interview la première chose dont
j'ai parlé c'est quoi c'est la précarité
j'étais là pour ça et au moment où on me
parle de trucs qui n'ont rien à voir on
ne parle pas de en plus vous me parlez
comme si voilà c'est pas comme si on
fait ce genre de réunion pour les jours
ces groupes de paroles c'est quoi ces
maximum deux fois par an pour que les
personnes s'expriment entre elles c'est
tout et quand vous dites qu'on se
soucierait pas des étudiants mais je
suis désolé monsieur le 16 mars qui
étaient dans la rue qui a organisé une
manifestation historique parce que il y
avait des étudiants dans la rue des
jeunes dans la rue alors que les
universités soient fermés mais je suis
désolé mais par contre le complotisme ça
aussi c'est un quelque chose qui
pourrait en appeler au lynchage de deux
professeurs n'a pas à dormir l'argent
les intérêts des extensions alors qua
non réalisés n'a pas il y aura sioniste
c'est prendre en main la saison passée
les spectateurs cette histoire
de grenoble il ya quelques jours l'une
est donc votre syndicat était déjà au
coeur d'un scandale après que la section
locale de grenoble avait partagé sur les
réseaux sociaux
les noms de professeur de sciences po
grenoble accusé d'une prétendue
islamophobie une affaire qui avait
provoqué bien entendu un tollé ça c'est
vrai que c'était également un violon de
gauche
ça vous a pas suffi samuel pâtit vous
voulez que y ait droit au passeur de
cannes et vous pensez vraiment que
samuel petit c'est notre responsabilité
parce qu'on a rien à voir avec ça non
mais c'est le genre de propos qui font
d'énormes est arrivé des choses
tragiques à d'autres professeurs
accueillent encore une fois je vais
répondre vous comptez juste continuer à
raconter des choses fausses à
l'interruption ou là dessus moi j'ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois que l'unef elle
n'était pas pour la chaîne publique de
qui que ce soit même quand il ya des
désaccords
même quand là on en enseignant en
l'occurrence qui a tenu des propos comme
je suis nazi de par mes gènes même quand
on dit ça va on n'affiche pas le nom des
personnes et c'est pour ça qu'on a à la
fois reconnu que c'était une erreur de
la part de la section locale d'avoir
publié je rappelle quand même que la
seule chose qui a été faite c'était des
photos du collage et c'était pas des
photos simplement de cette image là
c'était des photos qui rassemblait tout
le collage donc il y avait notamment un
collège qui dénoncé des agressions de
sciences po mais bon dans tous les cas
ça reste une erreur une erreur aussi
bien maladroite que dangereuse parce que
maladroite parce que bath a jamais été
l'objectif de lyncher que ce soir je
mets dangereux aussi parce que
effectivement c'est un risque sans vous
connaître et présenter nos excuses aux
enseignants et cette image a été très
rapidement supprimée
donc la sage grossir un peu le rôle de
l'unaf dans cette histoire et
franchement nous ici on essaie toujours
de voir les choses honnêtement je vous
le dis moi j'ai été étudiant la tôle
bien dire comme cyril lunettes j'ai
connu c'est effectivement un syndicat de
bouche mais un syndicat c'est une union
jeu honnêtement quand je vous entends
parler et notamment ce matin sur europe
1 et dans ton compte on n'interdit une
réunion à des blancs je vous jure que
imaginer imaginez la même chose on
aurait su que vous avez interdit
grillons et des noirs mais qu'est-ce qui
serait qu est ce qui se serait passé
on ne vous auriez eu un teint sans effet
un tollé gigantesque a justement une ou
deux fois tous les deux
je te dis tu nettoies effet un dénommé
simon peut pas on veut on peut
non mais on peut pas on peut passer vous
êtes un simple état pour unifier les
gens et vous est nettement en faisant ça
vous ne vous faites le contraire vous ne
fait que diviser les gens et celle
inverse de la fonction d'un syndicat
unifié les gens et wi fi des étudiants
et vous êtes linverse mais moi ça me
dérange profondément choquant le fait de
faire une réunion pour parler du racisme
et des discriminations raciales et que
vous interdisez la venue à des personnes
blanches c'est-à-dire de par leur
couleur de peau vous faites là un état
de racisme votre réunion sa rentrée le
rallye c'est du racisme n'importe quoi
je suis désolé qu'on a perdu opprimés
l'animé en réunion donc c'est quoi
contre échéant comprend quoi dans ces
réunions casillas qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qui se dit et nous mais là délaissés
lui la parole à mélanie qui est déjà
vous êtes nombreux face à elle voilà il
faut la laisser tranquille voilà qu elle
s laissez-la s'exprimer qu'elle nous
explique bien et arrêter de lui tomber
dessus mais là encore une fois quand
vous titre pour parler du racisme et
vous excellez blanc ces réunions se sont
encore une fois ce sont des groupes de
parole donc imaginez simplement des
femmes qui disent du sexisme qui sont
victimes d'agressions et vous demander à
ces femmes de libérer leur parole en
face de l'homme qui les a agressés
c'est un peu tard non laissez moi finir
de par les messieurs c'est le fils c'est
impossible si on fait le parallèle avec
du sexisme ordinaire dans ce cas là on
arrive à une situation une femme
allez on l'a traité de jeu c'est pas
hystérique cdu/csu mendy nerfs c'est pas
du tout le même impact que une agression
par contre lui demander de dénoncer ça
devant l'homme qui l'a accusé de cette
manière là c'est difficile mais c'est
pareil pour le racisme en fait donc 1
c'est pas interdit aux blancs stade il
n'y a pas un filtre à l'entrée qui dit
tu es blanc tu ne peux pas rentrer c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça se passe ce
sont simplement des groupes de parole
tout le monde est informé de sa et
toutes les personnes qui se sentent
concernées par le racisme peuvent venir
12 décembre
mais ensuite attendait excusez moi
laissez moi finir cette réunion c'est
comme je les dis c'est un partage de
témoignages
ensuite une synthèse qui fait pourquoi
pour anonymiser les témoignages et qu'on
puisse justement très clairement dire
voilà ce qui se passe dans
l'organisation c'est pas un tel cas dit
ça c'est ce qui se passe de manière
générale et ce compte-rendu on en
discute tous ensemble moi je suis les
mesures qu'ils soient prises
ce sera en tout cas veut dire que le fc
sion a service
en fait il doit déposer 10 fois plus de
cv pour avoir un emploi j'ai fait le
constat qu'aujourd'hui quand on mène à
ma tête
bah c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
d'avoir un logement je suis le constat
que oui je veux une société universelle
et pour avoir une société universelle
sont acceptés qu'aujourd'hui je vous
faisiez vous est très mince mais l'année
ils prenaient très près les années
douces on vous sent quand même très
affecté par cette affaire
mais enfin vous me dites c'est oui
bienvenue sur les réseaux sociaux je
suis désolé mais vous chance à les
réseaux sociaux normalement je vous dis
la ccsa assez pesant alors ressent très
affecté je vous sens au bout du bout du
rouleau
non mais c'est vrai vous les génomes et
je pense que cette histoire et cette
affaire il affectait ce que vous allez
continuer ces réunions mais bien sûr
vous allez continuer ce ne sont pas des
réunions interdites aux blancs je vais
pas faire des réunions interdites aux
blancs non encore une fois je vais faire
des groupes de parole dans lesquelles
les personnes qui vivent des
discriminations peuvent le faire doivent
remonter leur problème je suis désolé
mais alors est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va y avoir une dissolution de l'unef
non parce qu'elle n'a aucun fondement
juridique et par ailleurs il ya d'autres
organisations qui font ce genre de
réunion cette fois le public
nous on parle simplement de réunion
interne adressée aux militants il ya eu
notamment une plainte qui étaient
portées contre un syndicat qui avait
fait une réunion comme ça public cette
charte a été classée sans suite parce
que ce n'est pas de la discrimination
c'est simplement un cadre pour que les
personnes concernées par une
discrimination viennent s'exprimer et
ensuite je suis désolé mais un désaccord
ce n'est pas un motif de dissolution on
est dans une société démocratique le
pluralisme c'est important moi j'ai pas
de problème avec peut-être qu'ils aient
des désaccords vous pensez que notre
façon de lutter contre le racisme n'est
pas la bonne très bien c'est pas trop
mon objectif mais c'est marc contre il
n'empêche qu'on a le droit de parler
c'est la liberté d'expression qui lui a
pas laissé la liberté d'association
comporte ses téléspectateurs ouais vous
ça choquant
non à 14% il va falloir voilà mélanie
peut-être que vous fassiez des réunions
avec votre association votre syndicat
pour reparler de ça parce que maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est c'est compliqué et
on comprend pas très bien la différence
entre un mandat écrit et je vous avais
expliqué voilà je vous dis la vérité
pour peut-être remettre le discours un
peu voilà bien en place parce que là on
j'ai pas compris c'est pas bien pas de
parole est la différence entre ce que
vous avez dit sur europe 1 on a
l'impression que vous n'en prenez pas
conscience donc ça va pas changer
puisque vous ne prenez pas conscience on
prenait pas conscience de la dérive
parce que c'est un épisode parmi
d'autres à la naissance arrêter de faire
des idéologies des étudiants mais j'aime
aucune des étudiants et non par exemple
que vous parlez des étudiants en bts qui
sont là au bout de oboodi justement
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait si on est
étudiant à s'en sortir parce que
justement il demande un contrôle continu
mais qui n'en n'ont pas je veux vous
parler du fait que hier et en étudiant
qui justement a failli se défenestrer à
saint-etienne si je peux vous parler de
parler vêtues et toutes les remontées
que j'ai quotidiennement alors on chante
du suicide
alors le reste on recompte plateau bord
sur la précarité tu dois l'année sur la
réouverture des universités jo vont
soutenir à fond mais bien sûr c'est
derrière ce qu'on a besoin de gens comme
vous pour le faire mais sur ccc de ce
dossier là revoyez votre copie
voilà à mon avis merci juste excusez moi
mais je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui
voulait parler à tout le temps et par
l'oreille d'autres
j'ai écouté que moi et il me semble
quand même que c'est important et noir
il est revenu avec vous mais bien sûr
qu'il était venu avec moi mais j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une très grave a
ajouté guillaume genton aller non juste
le mot réunions interdites ou blanc ne
l'ait pas entendu dans la bouche de
melanie c les mots d'un sonnet mabrouk
sur repas je pense qu'elle a dû fermer
parler des personnes sont concernées et
selon elle les personnes concernées ce
sont les non blancs là je pense que
c'est maladroit parce que le racisme ça
concerne tout le monde
en revanche parler de dissolution là je
suis pas d'accord les associations pour
lesquelles on parle de dissolution c'est
une génération identitaire jeu qu'on
peut pas comparer lunettes et génération
identitaire moi j'ai réclamé la charge
en béton léger réclament la dissolution
de
l'unef à mon avis ne sont pas racistes
et génération identitaire qui sont
quasiment ouvertement raciste je pense
que c'est maladroit de leur chaleur sa
gravité et une agronome et honnêtement
l'unef j'ai trouvé que ça s'annonçait
déjà ce que dit eric normes génération
identitaire demandé l'arrêt migration
des juristes ne fais pas ça et par
ailleurs pourquoi aussi c'est pas
interdit aux blancs parce que
effectivement toute personne peut être
victime de racisme notamment des
personnes juives et donc l'antisémitisme
ça fait aussi partie n'en sais rien mais
vous triez